das sind die neuen zahlen rund 15.000
menschen bei denen das corona virus
nachgewiesen wurde
mehr als 300 menschen sind an dem virus
gestorben und 350 sind wieder gesund
keine beruhigende zahlen aber wir
sollten beim corona wehres zwei dinge
nicht tun
panik machen und vorhaben beides ist
falsch in diesem real tag möchte ich
noch einmal die fakten und die bisherige
entwicklung dokumentieren und erklären
warum die weltgesundheitsorganisation
wer diesen ausbruch für so gefährlich
hält und warum es mit panik überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat wenn man die risiken
kennt und sich wie die whu empfiehlt
vorbereitet weg zum science fiction gibt
es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen so stark sind
die fallzahlen der menschen mit
nachgewiesenem corona virus bisher noch
nicht gestiegen aber bei mehr als
100.000 verdachtsfällen ist es auch
nicht ungewöhnlich dass die labors nicht
mehr hinterherkommen neben der infektion
durch tröpfchen die zum beispiel beim
sprechen in die umwelt gelangen ist ein
weiterer infektionsweg entdeckt worden
und zwar über die verdauung spricht die
toilette ein anti dollar mittel könnte
möglicherweise auch gegen das corona
virus wirken in tierversuchen soll das
mittel wirksam gegen sarahs gewesen sein
ein verwandter des aktuellen corona
virus das mittel soll jetzt getestet
werden und es sieht so aus dass vor
allem ältere männer mit vorerkrankungen
gefährdet sind und kinder nicht daran
sterben
ja das sind die news aber richtig ist
auch zum heutigen tag besteht in
deutschland statistisch gesehen
überhaupt keine risiko an dem corona
virus erkranken alles ist im griff die
infizierten im luftwaffen airbus a310
die ausfuhren hier eingeflogen sind
wurden alle identifiziert und isoliert
während des fluges trugen alle
atemmasken insbesondere die infizierten
denn das ist das entscheidende das heißt
sie konnten keine anderen passagiere
anstecken auch in bayern wo immer mehr
infizierte entdeckt werden scheint es
keine gefahr zu geben der potenzielle
super verbreiter das kindergartenkind
war offensichtlich das letzte mal vor
dem workshop wollen wir pastor im
kindergarten so dass es im kindergarten
kein anderes kind anstecken konnte weil
es zu diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht
ansteckend gewesen sein konnte bei
diesem workshop war ja eine referentin
eine chinesin ohne symptome
die das virus aber verbreitet hatte weil
sie schon infiziert war
der vater des kindes hatte sich bei der
chinesin oder anderen teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmern des workshops infiziert
aber genau das ist auch das problem
dieses virus was wäre wenn was wäre wenn
das kind nach der ansteckung im
kindergarten andere kinder angesteckt
hätte einen nicht auszuschließendes
risiko und genau das fürchtet die vero
sie sieht die lage in china als unter
kontrolle an
aber das doch schon fast 200 menschen in
anderen ländern infiziert sind das ist
beunruhigend in china dagegen wird davon
ausgegangen dass die verbreitung in den
nächsten tagen stark zurückgeht weil
dann die quarantäne über die städte mit
millionen menschen greifen müsste um man
darf nicht vergessen auch wenn es
inzwischen hunderttausende fälle seien
dürften selbst das ist noch keine große
zahl für dieses riesige land wenn man
sie dann eindämmt aber was ist und das
ist die befürchtung wenn sich das virus
in einem entwicklungsland ausbreitet und
da ist es extrem befremdlich dass es in
südamerika und vor allem in afrika keine
fälle gibt mit afrika china besonders
aktiv handeln der kommunistische staat
hat dort flughäfen straßen eisenbahn und
energietrassen gebaut und tut das
weiterhin in die hand der stadt mit den
meisten infizierten stammen 5000
studierende aus afrika wieso gibt es
also keine infizierten in afrika
der böse verdacht der virus verbreitet
sich dort schon längst ungebremst
allerdings unentdeckt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu warnt
vor einer möglichen ausbreitung des
corona virus in afrika die vero geht
dabei davon aus dass gebiete mit hoher
dichte wie slums und flüchtlingslager
als brutstätten für die ausbreitung des
virus dienen könnten
zitat man kann leicht eine große anzahl
von fällen haben und das system kann
leicht überfordert werden aus diesem
grund ist die früherkennung von
entscheidender bedeutung dass sagt dr
michael laub programm manager für
noteinsätze im wahlbüro in afrika die
früherkennung gibt es dort allerdings
noch nicht und noch ist überhaupt nicht
klar wie die situation in afrika ist
allerdings stellte weber fest dass die
ressourcen bereits jetzt knapp bemessen
sind die länder dort sind bereits mit
den zahlreichen
und heitz risiken und solchen
ausgelastet in der demokratischen
republik kongo ist der ebola ausbruch
mit inzwischen 2000 toten immer noch
nicht gestoppt und der weltweit grösste
masern ausbruch im kongo mit rund 6000
toten ist auch noch nicht unter
kontrolle für beide erkrankungen gibt es
inzwischen impfstoffe bei einer
ausbreitung des corona virus dürfte das
allerdings anders sein und da bereiten
zwei umstände der extreme kopfschmerzen
kein mensch kann gegen dieses virus
antikörper haben das heißt alle können
daran erkranken und zweitens 10 bis 14
tage lang an eine infizierte personen
das virus unmerklich verbreiten so lange
dauert die inkubationszeit und trotzdem
ist dieser mensch schon anstecken und
deshalb geht nicht nur die wm sondern
auch zahlreiche virologen von einer
pandemie aus wir sollten also vorsichtig
sein wir sollten uns so verhalten dass
wir diese pandemie möglichst lange
hinauszögern denn dann kann bereits ein
impfstoff entwickelt worden sein im
moment müssen wir hier in deutschland
nicht besonders vorsichtig sein
doch wenn es hier drei oder vierstellige
zahl an infizierten geben sollte dann
müssen wir alle handlungsempfehlungen
der vero befolgen nur dann können wir
die schnelle ausbreitung der infektion
bremsen trotzdem muss dann dringend ein
impfstoff gefunden werden denn dann ist
die weltweite ausbreitung kaum noch
aufzuhalten und wie wir an der
spanischen grippe vor ziemlich genau 100
jahren gesehen haben ist das auch gar
nicht so außergewöhnlich wir sollten
also weder panik machen noch diesen
ausbruch verharmlosen er ist ernst und
wir sollten ihn deshalb auch ernst
nehmen alles andere wäre fahrlässig wir
bieten ab sofort hier mehr bei der
mitglieder von schon ab 299 bekommt ihr
jedes video vor allen anderen und können
schon kommentieren licon oder auch
dislike und ein paar goodies gibt es
auch dazu für infos kriegt unter diesem
video oder auf unser kanal seite auf den
button mitglied werden vielen dank für
den support sagen jetzt schon mal bis
dann bleibt dran